on change complètement de sujets si vous
voulez bien pour s'intéresser à
l'écrivain gabriel matzneff qui fait
l'objet de poursuites judiciaires pour
actes de pédophilie vous vous souvenez
de ce livre écrit par une femme qui
lorsqu'elle était mineure a 14 ans dit
avoir été abusée violée par gabriel
matzneff alors celui ci est actuellement
en italie mais nos confrères du new york
times l'ont retrouvée et puis bien un
grand article sur toutes les connexions
qu'avec gabriel matzneff dans un certain
nombre de milieux certaines étaient déjà
connus par exemple dans le milieu
littéraire on se souvient qu'il avait
eue en 2013 le prix renaudot
mais il y avait aussi on connaissait pas
forcément sa proximité avec yves saint
laurent avec pierre bergé avec un
collaborateur de l'époque du saint
laurent qui était christophe girard qui
est aujourd'hui adjoint à la culture de
la maire de paris et qui était intervenu
pour qu'il obtienne une forme de rente
délivrée par un organisme public
et pourtant l article le rappelle anne
charlène bezina les pratiques que
gabriel matzneff raconte dans ses livres
étaient déjà à l'époque interdit de se
dire que les relations sexuelles avec un
mineur de moins de 15 ans c'était ce
n'était pas quelque chose de tolérer
c'était quelque chose d'interdît
moi je trouve que dans ce mouvement
gabriel matzneff ya quelque chose du
balances ton siècle c'est à dire qu'on a
le sentiment que maintenant tout ce qui
a été supendue passer sous silence
on peut faire le parallèle avec le
milieu du sport en ce moment doit
doit être terminée la chose qui me
semblent majeur c'est que si on veut
changer les mentalités c'est bien de le
faire et aucune révolution qui se fasse
de manière totalement pacifique
néanmoins la question de la
rétroactivité moi me pose quelques
problèmes c'est à dire qu'on a ici
affaire à des faits qui ont été relatées
dans de multiples ouvrages
le journal était encore réédité en
octobre 2019
donc comment se fait-il qu'en 24 heures
ce qui était plus ou moins considérés
comme tolérable au niveau social il a
fait de nombreuses émissions bouillon de
culture etc où ils étaient reçus
apostrophe ils en parlaient très
longuement pourquoi ce qui était
tolérable auparavant devient aujourd'hui
à ce point-là intolérable dans les 24
heures
il ya quand même quelque chose à se
poser du point de vue de la justice
est-ce que cet appel à témoin là aussi
appel à victimes qui est quand même plus
ou moins renouveau de l'appel à témoins
dans l'enquêté pénale qui est censé
servir à réunir des éléments ici on
réunit des victimes donc sur la charge
de la preuve sur la présomption
d'innocence là aussi et le secret
d'instruction je trouve qu'on on fait
les choses à l'envers alors rappelle que
c'est le procureur de paris accélère au
curragh en fait appel à des appels à
témoins pour des actifs pourrait être
non prescrits à travers l'office de
protection des victimes qui est un
office qui est rattachée à la police
nationale qui du coup a la possibilité
de lancer des appels à témoins des
perquisitions pour évidemment enquêté ce
qu'on peut totalement comprendre
néanmoins c'est vrai que là on a le
sentiment déjà que c'est un roman qui
sert de base à une enquête pour des
faits qui sont connues depuis des années
il ya un risque un petit peu de de
donner le sentiment d'une justice à deux
vitesses la justice suit l'opinion c'est
une bonne chose mais à ce point là est
ce que il n'ya pas ce sentiment qu'en 24
heures on change la la norme la loi et
que peut-être on peut avoir à faire à
quelqu'un qui ne comprend plus la
législation qui lui est appliquée en
tout cas le l'échelonnement dans le
temps paraît quand même relativement
problématique r non
autre point de vue
pas exactement enfin je mange pas la
coque souvenez dire qu'il ait fait que
ça a été tolérée pendant des années ça
m'interroge plutôt sur la raison pour la
question qui devrait se poser pourquoi
est ce que la justice ait pas bouger
avant
et s'il ya eu ce livre qui est venu
stimuler la justice mais tant mieux il
ya une question qui est juridique et
alors là je connais pas assez la faire
pour me prononcer est ce que les faits
sont prescrits ou pas et puis une autre
question qui est politique sociale et ça
pourrait les faits pour être intervenu
il ya dix ans il ya 15 ans il ya vingt
ans où il ya cent ans
si les victimes ou les personnes qui se
disent victimes
si la société envie de poser le sujet
sur la table et en faire un débat public
ça me semble absolument légitime je
pense que ce qui est intéressant dans
l'article du new york times et laisser
ce qui soulève très bien c'est qui est
vrai pour probable au pour ce qu'elle
est ce que je comprends mais possible
plus largement à la cité français c'est
qu'il y ait une part l élite française
ce souk 3d se tolèrent pour elle des
faits qu'elle ne tolère pas de nom du
français moyen
il mêle je suis prêt à parier que d un
boucher d'une petite ville qui auraient
commis des actes pédophiles on serait
revendiqué il ya dix ans aurait eu
aurait déjà été aurait déjà eu des
problèmes avec la justice
il ya dans l'élite ce que dit le froid
que fut le meilleur times dit que c'est
l'aristocratie la vision reste aux
critiques françaises qui est très vrai
sur ce fait là comme d'autres dans
l'économie dans la vie politique qui
s'octroient des droits qui se tolèrent
de faire des choses qu'il ne tolérerait
pas pour l'ensemble des français
d'ailleurs elle fait des lois pour leur
interdire moi je trouve que le fait
qu'ils les faits qui sont reprochés à à
gabriel matzneff s'ils sont avérés je
crois qu'ils le sont si j'ai bien
compris ce que lui-même et à revendiquer
son doivent être sanctionnées si le
droit le père mais qu'ils étaient commis
il mène aujourd'hui et hier où il ya
vingt ans et je trouve plutôt sain que
ça arrive dans le débat public et le que
les gens que les personnes qui en ont
besoin est restée française dans son
ensemble se distingue à ces pratiques ne
sont pas tolérables et qui les annexes
inacceptable qu'elle a été tolérée moi
je crois que ça pose quand même une
question sociale et juridique comme vous
le dites le rôle de la prescription
c'est normalement que le droit et le
temps fassent bon ménage
si le droit et justice c'est pas pareil
le alors le droit alors si avec quatre
heures
mais c'est un immense sujet vient ici
une évolution la conception de la
justice sociale c'est à dire que
finalement et l'article démontrait bien
il y avait une forme d' exception
française qui faisait que l'écrivain
sulfureux était tout d'un coup
totalement tolérée voire même
complètement à la mode et qu' il a pu
commettre ces crimes et je ne suis je
suis loin de les justifier je suis une
femme et je veux bien passer pour dire
que en effet consentir poser la question
de la place de la femme dans cette
société et aussi de ce type d'agissement
et de ceux de cette mode de ces
agissements et évidemment quelque chose
dont nous devons discuter et dont nous
devons nous saisir mais pourquoi
maintenant
et pourquoi pendant si longtemps ça a
été une mode qui était non seulement
tolérable mais bienvenue donc c'est là
que le droit ne rencontre pas forcément
la justice sociale c'est qu'elle évolue
tellement vite qu'on n'avait pas les
moyens de s'adapter à ce changement de
société
mais il est bien de la société change
mais alors qu'elle n'attend pas que la
législation
la seconde à la minute près je trouve
que enquêter sur des faits qui ont eu
lieu il ya 40 ans pour la plupart
d'entre eux 30 au moins pose des
problèmes de prescription pose des
problèmes aussi d'apaisement des
victimes c'est à dire que aller
aujourd'hui rechercher des victimes qui
n'ont pas parlé pendant toutes ces
années c'est aussi remué un passé
vanessa spring aura dans son livre en
parle justement suffisamment clairement
en disant laisser quelques ça laisse
donc moi je crois qu'il ya un moment où
juger les coupables c'est une bonne
chose changer les états d'esprit aussi
mais il faut aussi que le temps puisse
apaiser les faits de la justice les
faits du droit à mon sens plus elle je
vous livre ses commentaires de nos
internautes 72% considèrent que oui il
faut faire le procès de l'élite
française procès évidemment entre
guillemets 1 alors que nathan 778
considère au contraire que c'est l'info
sujet que la bonne question serait
plutôt qu'en fera t-on respecter les
lois est sérieusement en france
et puis brigitte qui nous disent s'en
excuser ces gens répugnant il est
difficile de juger une époque après une
autre oui alors précisément la lèze cet
internaute a raison puisque c'est bien
d'une époque dont il s'agit à travers le
cas madoff qui est
olic mais on se dit tiens pourquoi tout
d'un coup alors que tout le monde savait
finalement collectivement et puis il a
fallu que il ya un verrou saute pour que
tout le monde parle mais on peut on peut
élargir cela puisque cette affaire
madoff a été l'occasion de de tirer le
fil
on a le sentiment que c'est la
pédophilie a été le lac mais de de
l'interdît d'interdire de mai 68
à un moment un certain nombre de gens
ont pensé que le verrou allait sauter il
n'a pas sauté je rappelle simplement
qu'à l'occasion de cette affaire madoff
on a eu erreur sorties ont été exhumés
un certain nombre de choses par exemple
une pétition pour la pédophilie enfin au
soutien des hommes qui avaient été
condamnés par pur pour pédophilie qui
avait été signé par jean-paul sartre et
simone de beauvoir qui aujourd'hui font
figure d'icône quand même je ne crois
pas qu'ils aient été supprimés des
ouvrages scolaires pour autant et il ya
un certain nombre de libérations
d'ailleurs par d'une façon assez honnête
on peut le dire puisque par son son
organe de la vérification des flec news
a répondu en disant est ce que
libération a soutenu par cette
compétition la pédophilie sont dits oui
si l'on doit répondre de façon exacte à
la question oui
donc c'est vrai qu'au delà de la sphère
mazev il ya ya ya toute une toute une
époque alors dit en balance son siècle
on balance son quart de siècle où son
demi siècle
mais il est important malgré tout
d'aller au bout du bout mais deux pas de
ne pas circonscrire parce que ce serait
assez malhonnête dans ces conditions
cela à cette affaire précise on peut on
peut faire le parallèle aussi vous
faites les parallèles entre différentes
affaires et je demande au président puis
la parole la sphère david hamilton avec
flavie flament aussi qu'ils étaient
tombés et qui est dans ce même type de
voile à d'icônes qu'on a pu sacralisé
jeu
je crois que c'est une question d'époque
enfin à l'époque la pédophilie il faut
rappeler que madoff
il allait aux philippines pour [ __ ]
des enfants de 8 ans c'est un
comportement de dégénérer ça a toujours
été traité comme un comportement de
dégénérer s'était pas de tolérer à
l'époque non plus faut pas faut pas
rêver le pédo tourisme c'est criminel
ça l'a toujours été quelle que soit
l'époque donc et ce côté omerta c'est
parce qu'il une caste effectivement lui
parle d'une secte d'ailleurs de ses amis
qu'il couvrait où il se refusait des
plans pédo et ça on n'en parle pas assez
roland jacquard qui a été quelque peu
mais rodrigue si du monde il a un blog
pédophiles qui est encore en ligne où il
parle de son amour des jeunes filles de
comment ça se fane très vite après 16
ans et c'est tout ça c'est toléré la
france est terre havre pour ces gens là
où on a laissé quand vous quand vous
commenciez à évoquer le problème qui se
passait au maroc avec pierre bergé vous
étiez tout de suite rayés des rayés de
la carte
nous n'avions plus de vie sociale c'est
l inverse ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est que la chasse aux prédateurs est
ouverte et c'est une bonne chose il faut
qu'il continue parce que la parole il
faut avoir le courage de ces gens qui
prennent la parole qui après des années
après le choc traumatique de dire je
vais être devant une caméra je vais
écrire un livre je vais dire ce qui
s'est passé en fin il m'a fallu toutes
ces années pour avoir ce courage là pour
le faire mais c'est incroyable mais les
gamins aux philippines qui avec lui la
gâcher la vie ils témoigneront pas il
n'y a pas d'appel à témoins à la barre
ils viendront pas c'est exactement le
cas pour brunel dans la sphère et
obstine vous avez ici quelqu'un qui
s'appelle jean luc brunel qui avait une
agence de mannequins qui était un
recruteur qui était un prédateur qui
envoyait aussi des gamines à son ami
obstine il a disparu la justice va pas
le chercher pour lui mettre le mettre
devant devant une cour parce que voilà
c'est prescrit que c'est à un moment
cette chasse aux prédateurs elle est
saine c'est une bonne chose et il est
temps que les victimes se disent
qu'elles sont pas victimes et elles ont
le droit à la justice parce que pendant
des années en fait réclamer justice
s'était vu comme comme inconvenant en
fait on ne parle pas de ça autour de du
dîner et enfin entre nous
ce qui est le préjudice supplémentaire
pour le reste de la société parce que
vous désirez une certaine élite une
certaine classe mais certains cas de
mandarins qui joue ses commandites et sa
gérance et garder oui nous sommes bien
qu'elle ait calé aux philippines avec
matt savoir le public était qu'ils sont
se couvrir mutuellement mais aussi
refusé toute la pensée c'est à dire que
si vous protestez vous étiez un petit
bourgeois étriqué a su avec des
principes attaque et pierre bergé
c'était impossible sur cette affaire-là
du maroc et de la pédophile mais je
pense qu'il y encore quelques verront
qu'ils méritent de hockey c'est pour ça
que c'est dès le but circonscrire un
début du renversement ou les prédateurs
se retrouvent chasser est une bonne
chose
ils ne comprennent pas et madness vous
voyez sa position c'est je comprends pas
je suis complètement ostracisé qu'est ce
qui se passe moi j'avais j'avais accès à
tous les salons parisiens et d'un seul
coup plus personne ne veut me voir parce
que vous avez beigbeder qui avec et créé
le club des mousquetaires avec lui qui
faisait des dîners qui était un grand
fan de mike neff beigbeder il est
toujours invité sur le plateau vous avez
comme be light i like qui est des écrits
pédophiles qui est invité sur les
plateaux et nommé des regrets d'ailleurs
informé c'est bien mais ça va quoi des
regrets parce qu'il faut sauver
justement l'apparence social croyez pas
que ça vous explique ce soit sincère
non ça suffit sortie gêné mais bon cette
gêne évidemment je n'ai fait éclater au
grand jour et par bernard pivot aussi à
aider a dit j'aurais pas dû car la
sélection son tweet sur greta aussi en
fait c'est toute une mi temps il a écrit
exactement
enfin ce top quoi stop on a cessé sa
malice est pas le seul auteurs dont les
ouvrages mérite mais alors à ce
moment-là si gallimard ne peut plus et
qu'on est en train de censurer la
censure c'est pas d'ascenseur se calment
ça n'a plus cours et je vois je m'en
fous je lisais maintenant mettre tout
coulait dans tous les gens qui étaient
dans cet entourage de au même niveau en
30 sûr que non cohn-bendit qui lui a
écrit voilà que c'était très excitant de
d'être des agriers par un petit enfant
et un beigbeder qui regrette d'avoir été
en faveur du renaudot passe et plus on
avait c'était des dîners c'était le club
des mousquetaires c'est beaucoup plus
que juste un prix littéraire
non c'est un mode de vie ok est ce que
chacun a pu exprimer publiquement en
effet je pense qu'il faut quand même
faire attention de ne pas tout confondre
les amis des pédophiles ne sont pas les
les pédophiles dans la mesure où il ne
soutenait pas dans leur entreprise
pédophiles en tournée avec tes jambes
rahmani avec marc nève s'il vous plaît
lui aussi devrait avoir le même souci
jacquard c'est la même chose
ces gens là c'était des touristes
sexuels français un concluant sur le
fait qu'on va laisser faire la justice
parce que c'est vrai que c'est à dire
qu'il sorte sur twitter ou autre ou même
à travers maintenant des ouvrages ça
pose quand même la question de ce que le
droit peut faire et de ce que les
victimes peuvent avoir comme
indemnisation après tant d'années